now first of all how much fun are you
having teasing your fans with your new
music too much
um no it's been it's been a real been a
laugh because when I last released music
the industry was completely different it
was literally like okay songs out next
week see you then
um no it's the whole tease and uh I love
winding them up that's my uh my game at
the moment I love winding these these
guys up and they're uh but they love
they love all the teasing all the at
least their eggs the the tick tocks the
the whole rollout has been really
interesting for me this time to see it
from a different side
it's so true it's been nearly three
years since you last released a single
how does it feel to be back
yeah no it's good to be back in the mix
it's uh I feel like I've gone from zero
to a thousand miles per hour in only a
few weeks
um once I handed in once I hand it in
the record to the record label it was
just game plan and when we're gonna do
it what we're gonna do at different
times and it's just been it's been a
hectic sort of couple of months but I've
been away for so long that I can't wait
you know if if it was up to me it would
have been out a long time ago but we
have to leave the record level to do it
our thing
but listen I think timing's everything
and I think this is the perfect time
especially because your fans been
wanting this so like they're ready your
song Heaven is so good it's been on
repeat all day for me I love that the
whole it has I love that the whole idea
is not conforming to what Society what
Society tells you to do especially when
it comes to Big Milestones that like
what do you just get married but you
have a big milestone birthday coming up
I do so I was just curious do you have
any Milestone moments that you would
love to accomplish personally for you
before you hit the age of 30.
great I haven't got long I've only got
like less than probably seven or eight
months I think you can do a lot
I would love to see the sofa release be
successful I think that that's I was
number one on the list because the
success of the music allows me to play
Big venues and you know I'll get books
and seats so uh that would be that would
be unbelievable if that could happen and
um I'd love to see how the album you
know releasing the album will be a big
one for me I haven't spent so much time
on it and um that to do well and then
yeah then get out and do some festivals
and then by the time that come by the
time that finishes that'll be 30 years
of age and uh we'll see where we're at
then
listen I can see this happening for you
um I just found out that your new album
is coming out and you're calling it The
Show What can fans expect yeah yeah the
show is the show was probably the first
thing I wrote down
when I started when I started writing
like ideas and Concepts and
titles and things like that for the
album it was kind of one of those
the album is basically like a bigger
thought and it's like you know how do we
life is like a show life is like a
you know it's it's things happen ups and
downs and stuff we can't control stuff
we can
um and I guess it was a good synopsis
title for for the album
um yeah it's probably my probably my
most mature work probably because I am
three or four years older than I was
when I last released music but um yeah
no I'm it's the most complete as well
like I feel like it's
it's got a bit of everything in there
and it all sounds like it's from the
same records if you know what I mean by
that that's obviously it's obviously on
the same record but you know what I mean
they all they all sound like they're
from a similar world
and when you say mature do you mean
themes lyrics the tone the fact that you
feel more confident yeah I think I'd say
a good mix of everything there
um you know to
to the sound of it is a little bit more
mature
um it's beefier the ballots are a bit
more thought out
um generally speaking I'm usually like
uh quite like a
Storyteller in the lyric and and pick a
scenario and really
write every detail of it
um and this time having spent so much
time sitting around in my own head
during the pandemic I feel like the
thoughts are just a little bit bigger I
guess that comes with with age and stuff
like that but um
across the board Between Heaven and the
title of the album it seems to be
sounding a little bit more mature in
Imagine yeah that's so exciting all
right so you have a song called heaven
so I have to ask what is your version of
heaven look like
better be a golf course
[Laughter]
um and I would play a gig every day
to
as many thousands as I had as I could
um and to be lovely pubs everywhere
and it'd be 20 you know be like 23
degrees Celsius every day yes
tiny bit of a breeze it would just be
it'd be a dream everyone's welcome
that sounds perfect I've recently
discovered that you not only have a love
for Cardigans but you have a massive
collection of Cardigans so if you have
to pick between your love of golf or
your love of Cardigans what would you
pick I don't have to go with gold
Cardigans are for Cardigans are for a
certain time of year as it goes for life
good answer I feel like you've been
asked that before because I came quick
that was hard hitting yeah
that was my Oprah question for you yeah
um it's really exciting obviously so
many of us watch the Grammys Harry
Styles took Home album of the year and
you posted A really lovely message of
support have you texted him or called
him since he won the Grammy yeah yeah of
course the Texans right away when the
minute was finished
um you know to congratulate and he wrote
back it was it was really cool to see
him up there collecting multiple Awards
on you know arguably you know music's
biggest night so he deserves it the
record is unbelievable and he's uh he's
worked hard at it and he's toured like
like crazy and he's done it all for this
album standout so only good things for
for Harry very happy
I love that and I know you love you know
the fans love seeing the continued
support with all of you guys in One
Direction
um The X Factor UK actually posted a
video a behind the scenes video of how
the judges put together one direction
did you know that you were picked first
or did you find out when we all did
yeah I
don't know when when that video came out
I seen it
I was like see
dogs it's always going to be built
around me
we're back we'll go find that out that
was pretty cool they obviously had a lot
of folders in front of them they slid
them around and mine happened to be
first on that list so uh
they obviously had a fair idea of food
we were going to put in there I guess I
didn't really I actually didn't know any
of that like it's crazy after all the
time I've spent retirement over the
years and we were asking how the band
was put together and how he chose us but
I never really never realized actually
how it was done logistically it's pretty
cool yeah because that was been well
that was been done myself and Harry were
out on the steps of the venue with our
suitcase is like ready to go home and
then they're sliding pictures around
inside and then the rest is history I
guess and then your whole life changed
what happened what happened
um you know when you were teasing or as
you continue to tease this new music we
see a video of you in the car you know
singing along to Heaven is there a song
that you love to belt out when you're in
the car by yourself
that's a good question there's a lot of
songs
um what I think of driving
in the sunshine I always think like
Fleetwood Mac and very Californian type
music any of that rumors album any Eagle
stuff I'm always belting it out
um Shania
hello Shania
um yeah anything that makes me feel
windows down Sunshine I'll stick on
amazing do you have a favorite Shania
song
is probably one of the great songs of
all time my eyes oh
um so good the valid
and she's uh she's actually Any Man of
Mine I like that
love that
um can you do a cover of that song
please thank you oh yeah that would be
great
and I love Shania she's always been a
huge supporter of mine and uh came to a
gig of mine a few years ago always keeps
in touch sent me her album last week
with a assigned little note inside which
was nice and one of those you know those
PR box things
um yeah and she's just she's she's so
good to like younger artists and
you know and things like that she's and
she's one of your own obviously and she
is that's why I'm like so impressed this
is a friendship I didn't even know I
needed and now I want more of yeah so do
I I would uh yeah she's she's the best
um lovely lady I love that I want to ask
you really quickly about your amazing
friendship with Louis Capaldi uh you
guys were in a car together going across
Ireland what is the best thing about
being in a stuck with being in a car
stuck with blue list and the worst thing
uh
the best thing is the series laughs that
we have like they literally just there
was no such thing as action it was very
much it was like a lot of GoPros in the
car
um we were miked up whatever but it was
literally us driving around the country
and that's where we got all the good
stuff from I'd say the worst thing is um
the constant farting
and and uh I thought I could swear I
thought I was a cursor you know I swear
like a sailor but um Capaldi's got a
one-up on me on that one for sure so
every SEC every second world is a beep
that is always entertaining listen I got
the wrap but I just want to say I cannot
wait to see you on the Voice you are
going to kill it hopefully that's gonna
be no the voice is gonna be great this
is where the talent on the show is like
that's the thing we go through the
auditions we see loads and loads of
people and every one of them are good
um are great singers so that makes for
for good TV and we're having a laugh in
the big red chairs so
tune in album's coming out singles
coming out it's going to be a good year
get used to this face you're going to
see a lot of it Canada
yay our prayers have been answered thank
you so much now congrats on everything
thank you Morgan I'll see you soon yeah
see you soon bye